Hi, Mark Turrell, CEO of Imaginatik and I'm
speaking to you here live from the World Economic
Summit Davos in China. I'm delighted to be
here. The question I've been asked for comments
is will China pull us out of the economic
crisis? I think that there's such a global
economy and we're so interconnected that there's
no one country that can actually pull us out
of any form of crisis. I think this is something
that we can join together sort of pull ourselves
down and we can join together sort of pull
ourselves up. But I think if one just looks
at getting out of the crisis in general, what
I'd really like to highlight and enforce is
that the real thing that helps to get out
of crisis and helps growing is innovation.
So the need to systematically do things from
business processes, business models, new products,
new technologies, just the creation of innovation
is that focus on innovation and I think that
what is very important is that countries and
companies do not lose the focus in innovation
and continue to invest in innovation. I think
China is a good example of a country that
is really trying to be more and more innovative
and make more investments but at the same
time really, Europe and the United States
put a huge track record with innovation. So
I think then while trying to pull us out of
the economic crisis no not by itself, we all
have to pull ourselves out but the thing [inaudible].
Thank you very much for giving me the opportunity.
Thanks.